the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
okay a recap of four last lecture there
are many many many terminologies in the
last lecture we basically start from the
boards my equation under relaxation time
approximation and we derived the
expression for the charge flux current
flux which current density and also for
the heat carried by the charge and so we
have the cup of the equation for
electrical transport I have to like I
point out before I use a different
symbol je and Jake Hill je is a four
electron Jake hill in the book of the
full heat and the always the challenge
is a deal with the negative sign of
electron so i put a cue small Q just
before whatever is a positive with the
foot hole negative that's for electrons
and then I use it Kepler kill so that's
what I did in last lecture and so we
have those coupled equations and those
those type of coupling is a very common
when you deal with see the transport
processes here we do the electron and
the heat coupling I said when you do
piezo electric and heat and mass
transfer there are all those type of
relations and if you generalize the
gradient by the generalized entropy
gradient as the force then you have the
answer correlation to turn those
carpeting coefficient in the generalized
form those coupling coefficient a G
equal to each other but the since we're
not writing into the entropy we write in
temperature so l 2 y equals T 012 in
this specific expression we we use and
from this is lecture to have to say
when you have a temperature gradient you
also have even in the open circuit case
or any conductor or semiconductor you
have the seat back I have voltage
generally if you have temperature
gradient and the pouty effect is when
you have a charge flow in the conductor
even if you don't have time to a
gradient associate with charge flow is
the heat current is the heat flow and
that's the pouty a heat which is a
manifested itself when you put two
mature together and form a junction and
because discontinuity in this paltry
coefficient you have cooling or heating
I the junction but fundamentally it's a
a fact that happens in the same material
right so we talk about the material
properties sit back if I seebeck
coefficient pelletier coefficient
material properties and similarly
Thompson effect is the seat back and the
party or actually experimenter II are
discovered but Thompson factor is North
Kelvin predicted when they try to unify
and give us a general interpretation of
what's the seat back and what's up LD
Fagin and he discovered there has to be
a third in fact that's when you have a
temperature gradient and the current
flow at the same time in the material
then you have distributed local cooling
and heating along every point in the
material so the relation between those
coefficients Calvin relations and you
can see there are a lot of relations
that's because all those expression flux
expression is derived that I listed
under the framework we're talking the
relaxation time approximation you don't
have to use that but they eventually the
those coefficients are all related back
into the relaxation time right so we
have see the relation between electric
conductivity and thermal conductivity
for charged with my friends law we
have relationship you to a party and sit
back effect that's Calvin relation we
also have in the electrical engineer say
the drift diffusion equation which is
actually just the first term of that JQ
l 1 why is the electric conductivity and
then we write into the separate
expression right when we split out the
driving force for the current flow which
is electrochemical potential they
include the chemical potential an
electrostatic potential the chemical
potential is related to the carrier
density so that's a gradient that's a
diffusion term and you'll actually
starting potential give you the force
electrical force acting on the chart so
that drives the drift so drift is a
measure with the mobility diffusion is
diffusivity and again the relation
between diffusivity and mobility is the
Einstein relation and in fact the
Einstein relation I'm accommodate
Einstein didn't do electron a day to day
Brownian motion for molecules and he has
relation between the mass diffusivity
and the viscosity and that's special
case all those has special kids as they
offer the fluctuation dissipation theory
so the fluctuation gives the Brownian
motion diffusion and dissipation is the
viscosity mobility that's the coalition
so the authors are tied together a lot
of terminology but they are
intrinsically all connected
and by the end of the lecture we want to
discuss the thermoelectric device a real
device is typically made of pairs of P
and N and you collect them electrically
by see typically is the metal and then
say this is the basic construction unit
and you repeat them many times in a
commercial device and the reason for us
for this you connect the many of them
together is because tip curves ZT
summarize a electric figure of Merit
when you get a ZT the largest case in
commercial material which is business
turn right please write the seat back
eyes of the order 200 micro watt per
Kelvin and the electric conductivity is
of the 10 to the 5th on per meter and
the on per meter inverse on per me si is
also semen so this is CNN per meter or
semen from inner different unit right so
10 to the face so the mature is actually
very conductive metals electric
conductivity is 10 to the eighth of the
order oh yeah I think it's in order two
or three order magnitude higher then to
this simac on the semiconductor
typically we use either commented doping
concentration is run into the line teens
right and if you make a silicon device
and in microelectronics the doping
concentration is a typical 10 to the
17th so to order magnitude smaller so
this is a each leg it's about a
millimeter in commercial device and the
resistance electrical resistance is a
minute hope so when you have many oh you
got a large current and they so you put
us a lot of legs together
earth to increase the electrical
resistance and that way you your
operation is easier you don't have to
have the large current operation and the
thermal conductivity is made of
electronic contribution and the Fallen
contribution and this is of the order 1
watt meter Kelvin ok and this value is
of comparable to glass glasses 1.2 right
and this is a similar United tubular
materials actually about 1.5 and so you
want a material with a high electric
conductivity no thermal conductivity and
you want to each electron carry a lot of
heat seabeck is the entropy averaging
entropy carry the per charge I mentioned
right so that's the dilemma here you
have to play with the material so you
try to it turns out that you change one
you also most of time a change in the
orders and there is a light terminology
to describe what you really want you
want this is a so called a fallen glass
so for lattice vibration you want it
like a glass which is an office right
and amorphous material typically do not
conduct the electricity well so you want
the electron crystal right so fall on
glass electron crystal but you want this
happen in this in mature so this is
where the challenge is and trying to
fool the material for the lattice
vibration you say this is like a very
poor heat conductor and the four
electron is like a good electric
conductor and typically these must turn
right why it's good it's because it's a
heavy and winds heavy the following
frequency is low the group velocity is
small and intrinsically the thermal
conductivity is going to be lower and
the other way to use it to reduce
thermal conductivity by alloy right the
mask a turn for example silicon so
150 germanium is about lightning and
when you mix the atom together the
difference so the master now if you
think about having a chant if each atom
is the same you got a harmonic vibration
very harmonic but they each match point
you put a different mass you know that
string is not going to vibrate very well
and that's the mass different scattering
alloy scattered and that's the typical
way to reduce the thermal connectivity
and of course you want to do it to not
to reduce the electric conductivity ok
so we we discussed the summer of the
typical heuristic over s Sigma K and if
you engineer which they also say your
own most of your engineers so what's
important is to match ok it turns out
the device you can size the differently
across washing area height and you
actually have to match the two sides
because the analysis I gave it to one
neck you when you put a two-leg together
you'll say area thence ratio has to be
matched to get a maximum performance so
there are a lot of optimization at the
both matures level and also at the
device level ok ah any questions so sir
so if you look at the energy research
right and right now there are a lot of
full of course a great interest and and
look energy devices there are not many
stuff right a lot of people work on
solar cells a lot of people work on
batteries and the rest is you just say
people all want to work on resource a
energy-related so you're starting to see
a lot of people now work on
thermoelectrics right but actually
thermoelectric is the fun in the sense
you really have to fool the material
right and it goes into long linear
regime ready or everything is the
scattering you want to control transport
you have to control this scattering so
it's both difficult and if you like it
it's fun okay don't like f it's a
headache when i got into thermoelectrics
the first a thermal a trade program so
if you look at history right in 9 18 21
c back discover the effect around the
1900 this is a parameters each he was
formulated so how you make a generator
you need a material with high Z key and
the run line in 50 a business Turner I'd
was discovered and that's when so this
was a bike go Smith and when he
discovered this monster he said that he
was just it's actually very lucky he
said the first guess he found it he has
a good physical inside so you need a
heavy material having mature turn shadow
also usually have better mobility okay
charge mobility and I said we tried this
one terrorizer and it worked and so most
commercial device was based on Dismas
turn right and then say info power
generation Lhasa see it was interested
because the solid state and it's the
best I but you have to go to higher
temperature business turn right is not
stable so they went to a silicon silicon
germanium is by the idea of alloy that's
the Russian scientist I off a proposed
the alluring can reduce thermal
conductivity so that led to development
secant germanium and silicon germanium
has been used in most Lhasa flight for
deep-space missions and they use a
nuclear with new Tanaka nuclear waste is
a nuclear fuel to generate the
temperature difference generate heat and
that has a turn out of four spaces very
reliable and they those are generator
work not very efficient five to six
percent
they've been sending back a signal some
of those space missions over 30 years
right and but for cooling it's been some
bismuth her I'd most tourists or
applications based on business turn
right so commercial modules or used
pretty much the mature developing the
50s 60s so uh they're not much research
in this and in ninety around in the line
is right so there are people they prove
this is a some time they also have to
give credit to the program manager and
they started asking whether there is
anything new in thermoelectrics okay and
one of the person they asked it was a
milli dresselhaus and so Millie Millie
said told me all the story and she said
it was not actually the military was a
friend that I keep talking somebody here
an impasse in conference and get her
told her about thermoelectrics and then
when the military came me ask her
whether she had idea there was happened
to be a graduate student looking for
research topic and so he asking him to
calculate the quantum well okay so the
idea of a quantum well right we want a s
square Sigma electron better right if we
look at the density of states off of our
bulk material right that's a square root
II relation right it's parabolic things
up stays right and this is a energy I
remember here is a you say and depends
on where you put a EF right I said the
EF if you put it here this if this is a
EF you'll dope it and then we say they
are see back is measure of the average
energy from the EF right so electrons
there
no electron below you see this back gap
semiconductors so most electrons in this
region right because the fermi-dirac the
fermi-dirac ax is EF at the EF 0 is the
point 5 distribution and the exponential
decay very rapidly so there are not many
you like so if you plotted a per energy
level what's the occupancy is this is
the fermi-dirac distribution and this
times this means they're only this is
you see only a small portion these are
the portion that contribute to charge
transfer you look at your the expression
for electrical activity you have this
homework of looking at a different
product right so only electron near the
sea ec bottom here contribute to the
transport the rest is too high energy
they don't they don't they are not feel
their empty States there okay so in this
so here is EC and that the problem with
this is here a typical pro-bono pounds
right there are not many carriers here
you look at it right this is the lowest
density of states region not many energy
carriers so I you did a density of
states on quantum well a quantum well is
staircase right so now rather than this
parabolic you have a staircase and of
course you dope it again in suddenly you
got a lot of carrier here right and so
carrier number of care is proportional
to the electric conductivity so by
making this shop fisher and then you
control your dope in you can get
theoretically you can get a larger s
square Sigma so this was the first paper
published by hicks and rest house on
this using quantum ideas to increase the
S square Sigma and Millie is say expert
on business
so she's the expert on carbon and
business kaban she wrote the important
paper that's before carbon nanotubes was
discovered she'd be always talking about
the car bong and she wrapped that up and
the neighbor say woody for the energy
level if you have a tube right so must
escape the know reprise skip that they
come on aren't you she missed that right
it was went from the c60 the Richard
Smalley discovered carbon 60 and you
know last year went to the graphene
right so the tube was missed anyway so
always do very conceptual very simple
but made a big impact right and this is
a this is an idea that is doing the sea
quantum well and the other ideas she had
was say business is a semi metal okay
there's no gap so you have a equal
number of electron and holes and the
Seebeck coefficient slow because they
cancel each other and so you should say
okay if you use this quantum size effect
that's your quiz exam right electron
move up host move down so you turn that
similar metal into a semiconductor so by
using size theoretically all those are
the possibility and the increase and
really drove a lot of interest in this
problem so that was around 93 and and at
a year I didn't know anything about
thermal electrics I was working on
semicond are lasers and I was worried
that heat cannot get out so these are
lasers has a lot of layer structure and
that's the quarter if you recall the
brog reflectors right Brock reflector
are the quarter wavelength layers and I
know that
the mean free path observer I thought
this has low thermal conductivity first
I think it was the stop band may reduce
thermal connectivity I but she also the
classical sized affect the mean free
path could be larger than the thickness
and that can have a lower thermocline so
that's what I was interesting but I
didn't know anything about
thermoelectrics and here a program came
out in 96 and learn this or somebody say
oh you should look at it so I look like
that I say ah that's what they need I
see I can work on the denominator here
and team up with mini I work on the
numerator so it took me five years to at
least get to really know what these
thermoelectrics but we had a finely and
learning this so there are a lot of
current research in thermal electrics
and many many different ideas the
challenge is putting into real material
there are always things that you didn't
quite realize and most idea dhoom work
okay but you have to keep thinking so
there are a lot of progress made in the
field ok that's the comment down
thermoelectrics and now let's come in
back continue a few more things in this
chapter the question is so in all the
previous like a course you probably
heard about the local you could never
write you when you do our heat transfer
say we say talk about lokor equal what
does the local equitable equally bore me
right so what is the local you Queenie
bro
and we know if object is at the
equilibrium the / energy states he obeys
the fermi-dirac a bose-einstein
distribution right and those
distribution is isotropic so this is the
f0 when we solve right f0 is isotropic
that's the equal number in each there is
no net flux because they're equal amount
of acidity or charging any direction
versus the opposite direction so you
don't have left flux that's a eukanuba
and if you look at the water with the
simplest form of a solution it's a tall
way we XD f d 0 DX right this is the
simplest form we used to derive the
Furillo for example and you plot e this
is under D so this is how we derive
forreal alright so what really is given
the flux is the deviation this term is
given the flux f0 does not give you the
flux so if I plot the F itself in the
forward direction if this is my flocks
the Russian in the backward direction is
this so what I have the difference
between the two is this section that's
what the going forward the left forward
and that's less going backward it's this
tool contributing to the real flocks ok
so what locally could even means is this
deviation is small from the equitable
that's how assumption right when we do
the perturbation f equals f 0 plus G
this is
gee small comer to f0 is the under dat
approximation we can derive the Furillo
we can directly with a shear stress low
on home small so no core equilibrium
still means there's no equilibrium here
what I have is no eukanuba right it's
just a deviation from the equilibrium
small okay and so then we can ask her
what are the conditions when this allow
longer valid right so if I go back to
the Boltzmann equation under relaxation
time is a way and the let's say Delta RF
I can see just consider the case of fall
on and the electron has a momentum term
right so what I want is a F minus f0 to
be small compared r2f itself right so
the I can think about the condition I
have then is here let's say tau way x DF
0 DX must be much smaller than f of 0
that's my condition for the perturbation
and now if i do the order magnitude
right how we x is the mean free path ok
so this order magnitude is a mean free
path and f 0 TF 0 DX i can say F over
the L this is an order magnitude I have
right I'm not doing anything exactly i'm
doing approximate derivative by f / f 0
/ l l is your transport or whatever
gradient direction right
I'm sorry ah this is not an equation
this is a hand waving yeah here lift all
sharks are yes thank you yeah here I
yeah okay so what I have here is a ham
living right when you do order magnitude
analysis you rather gradient by say
finite-difference term and give you this
to the order and so what it tells me one
condition is the mean free path is much
smaller than curry skillet when the new
free parts are comparable to the car
disabilities of transport the assumption
is not valid right so that's one RC
condition and this is the where most of
the time we going to do Michael narrow
will concern the where we fall into the
size effect regime when the mean free
plasma has longer than courage goodness
in fact you can see do another that's
right mean free path DF 0 I DX i write a
DF 0 d t + DT DX and less than the f0 ok
and again I do this over T this order
magnitude speaking f0 kinds on this side
dt DX DT DX is delta T over L much less
than one right so what I what I am
saying here is the gradient DT DX right
should be much less than you can look at
it temperature or movie
the reason I say this is for this case
it's very easy if I do a film the mean
free path is longer than the film
thickness I will have a size effect
right and I'm concerned that the locally
Queenie born sumption me love you value
but there's another case where my
temperature gradient is too deep right
if I have a transient transport and the
temperature gradient the varies a lot
over one min free pass right then this
is a see also a concern your see foolio
law may not be valid and the third case
is real transit right if I look at the
transient term this one I proxy DF 0dt
right and that also should be much
smaller so what say the time wise you
can look at that this is a towel over T
must be much smaller than one relaxation
time versus to the transport process
much much smaller than one ok so these
are the conditions for this no kuro u
knierim assumption to be valid and then
when the love Ali you see and it will be
very right and one way to one equation
that's very famous called the canton
equation it's trying to address this
issue okay and this is the rationale the
historical development for this
transient problem is if you look at a
semi-infinite object and you solve the
heat conduction equation for semi
infinite object it's a parabolic
equation the temperature decay
exponentially but the exponential decay
means at T equals zero you give the
temperature
the surface a disturbance in another way
there is a fein in their infinite small
by the infant but it's not zero right so
that means the heat is propagating
faster than speed of light so that's a
dilemma in the foolio heat conduction
equation right and one of those
approximation of the reason to the way
of the equation 2 to answer this is
modify this heat conduction equation as
a Q equals minus K DT DX this is called
the Cantonian equation okay but I say so
there are hundreds of paper read on this
because you have a new equation there
are always people a good at math solving
there okay but they see this is most of
their time is not correct because to say
if you go to look at the board's my
equation here right you go to hear in
fact I say you find that you can
transform you put it all on to the other
side oh my here it should be at all okay
otherwise the unit is now right right so
you put it all on this side you
integrate times the velocity times the H
Omega times dense upstate so you
integrate both sides right you will
actually get this term you get this term
that's this term here and it's this term
you approximate it still with the
Furillo okay so I see this is the most
of time is academic exercise because
when you have verge fast temperature
process you're greeted the gradient term
the spatial gradient the typically
exists and because of spatial gradient
your you cannot approximate this term
by the full relo that's the because
we're doing dfz we're replacing that
gradient f by f 0 okay so this is what I
say there are many PhD Citizen Aliss and
say I say that's a waste of time and
unfortunately and you have to really
understand what you're doing when you
deal with those okay so comment that's
one comment the let's come and I want to
make I'm not going to go into the detail
it's all in the book the interesting can
rate so what if we have derived is a
constitutive relation right the relation
between temperature gradient the heat
flux velocity gradient shear stress
right your actual chemical potential
gradient car that's constitutive
relation and you can actually start with
the boards my equation derived
conservation equations and so if you
recall when you derive the navier-stocks
equation for fluid flow what do you use
before or you dry heat conduction
equation you used a considerable
relation together with the energy and
momentum balance sequent conservation
equations that's how you derive those
equations right and you can start the
from the boards my equation and you take
the movement okay f is the distribution
function in phase space right so if you
multiply by the mass per particular on
both sides and then you integrate you
have to do summation over all the put
states on both sides you will get mass
conservation equation
okay and if you do so this is a day /
particular because when we do or the
navier-stocks equation or heat
conduction question we don't we do not
have any variable in the momentum space
it's real space variable right so when
we sum up all the momentum variable you
take that you're taking the average on
both sides of the mass total mass say
any location there and if you do your
momentum you put in the momentum per
particle into the boards my equation and
again your average both sides you will
get at the left hand side you will have
the compassion term in the navier
strokes equation on the right hand side
you'll get the the the right hand side
of navier stokes a pressure and the nude
ensure stress the shear stress term with
custom right but there you still have to
put in the constellation right so to get
the Newton's your stress so you you see
here you still are using the
approximation navier strokes equation is
approximation because you approximately
the Newlands your stick stress term
there and same you can do energy so on
this side say the fluids that has more
higher order you can do higher order
moments and their modification to liquid
stocks equations but what's interesting
is that you go to look at the history of
an electrical engineer right and in the
1980s the electric engineer start doing
simpson and they derive the electoral
hydro dynamic equation electric for
electron transport so you go to check
the derivation I think of the in my book
their reference to this you check out
the dryer evasion and so in 98 and the
literature lining 88 a lot
the paper trying to solve electro
hydrodynamic equation and the reason for
that is they ieva at a time the gate
lens is becoming smaller and people were
the size the effects so they went to
electro hydrodynamics and of course if
you look back if I say they are said
that seems to be really not the right
approach because they we know the louis
stokes equation is not valid that when
the mean free path is say longer than
the car is secure transport dimension
right so when you do hydrodynamic you're
not solving that problem you still doing
the local equilibrium and of course the
high feel that there is a conversion so
that those students with me so hobby
electron effect and may be captured so
ah and I do not think there are really
many people nowadays solving electro
hydro dynamic equation but the e when
you go to check their the electron shear
stress electron temperature very fuzzy
the discussion there were very fuzzy in
the literature and then you go to fall
on right there also foula hydro dynamic
equation this were in Russian literature
and nobody has solved it I haven't
solved many solution and so so so you
see there it's also it's at the point is
all related right and a different fields
that has a probably some failed
developed tools and the other people
learn and apply to different problems
let's say you got to understand the word
at the basis when you apply it so that's
all on this chapter 6 which is a really
starting from they say the particle
transport and when we learn that they
are the diffusion theory and what we're
moving on is looking into classic or
size effect that's a chapter
seven okay so now we get into want to
look at the regime when those
approximations a lot valid right and we
can start with the problem where I'm
looking at heat conduction I do heat
transfer now picon conduction along a
thin film freestanding thin film okay
and let's say the mean free path we know
the mean free paths of photons and under
the mean free path is longer than the
film thickness D ok now the even though
I have let me first consider the
transport along X direction so my Q is
flowing along the film right and you
know the Q is flowing down the film we
know the photons go out the Russians
right so for Lance the momentum space
you go if it goes this direction and the
mean free path if it's a number than the
distance I draw here you will collide
with the boundary and of course once
cried with the boundary they will be
scattered reflected right and that
depends on the boundary condition
roughness for example at the boundary we
know when light hits the surface like a
table here it's a diffuse scatter if you
put a mirror their soup spectral
reflected reality maybe somewhere in
between and this is in fact still nobody
really know what's happening at the
boundary right so the assumption will be
doing first is a diffuse so is isotropic
scattering to all the rations
and in this case conceptually you know
your heart will put worst heat
conduction then when you don't have the
boundary because otherwise the heat will
go from here lately this is mean free
paths in bulk material heat will go from
here to here that means at least the
distance wise in X Direction is dis
distance but now because the diffuse
scattering hit the boundary half of them
were going back much earlier right so
those kind of size effect typically will
impede your transport and let's go to
see what the equation tells us I'm going
to solve this equation the Fourier law
and I have an extra ration and let's say
the extra rations very long is not a fun
but see why the Russian is a final right
so we have I in this case I have we x DF
DX plus let's say here is y direction
levi DF D Y as either rushing I don't
have a gradient so i can drop that z i'm
only considering the x-direction flow so
I have minus F months f 0 steady state
over tau this is a and this is the
equation one to solve and I'm going to
again look how the at least let's see i
have two direction DF DX in the
x-direction right so if i do G equals F
minus f0 smooth say not lesser small
deviation but this is my difference
there and what other i substitute this
into the equation here what i gather the
way x DF 0 DX
ok and then DG DX but the X Direction my
variation is relative small right i hope
i set the exploration a very long very
long so that deviation DG DX that can be
dropped out so what I have is way XD f 0
d x and y direction so DF 0 DX f 0 then
is a function of X I have 1d transport
so DF 0 dy also drops out so what I have
is a way why d GG why an equation minus
G over tub ok
so this is a what I really am looking at
it is the variation because of the
boundary the in the Y direction I have
variation size dependence on the
distribution so different point I have
different F in the right direction and
so what I'm going to look at when I
rewrite this equation wave i DG dy plus
G over tau and the equals negative way x
DF 0 dt dt DX so you can say if i do not
keep the first term that's essentially
what I had before I'm only keeping an
extra term due to the constraint in the
Y direction ok now you can solve this
first order differential equation for G
and if the first order differential
equation how many boundary condition you
live yeah somebody can
speak out
you know it's only one right you need
the only one boundary condition you need
a one boundary condition for any pair of
vxvy because vxvy I'll run the facespace
verb right so basically what is saying
is you say here i need the ration look
at this is the direction that the
propagating and then you need a boundary
condition in this direction and the
added point if it's the internal point i
have the ration propagating 360 degree
or space and this one coming from here
so i need a boundary condition either on
this surface on this surface and if you
can specify web surface for 360 degree
makes a 4 pi saw the angle you find only
started with one surface but most of the
time because i have two constraints and
it's better to do for the one the
traveling this from leaving this surface
i have boundary condition here for this
half punk bottom so that together gives
me 4 pi solid space real space ok so now
let's solve this and we've I and so this
is a at any point right this is why the
Russian and the X Direction any point
let's say that this is a way we buy VX
let's determine the propagation
direction and it's again your choice
whether you use a Cartesian coordinate
or using spherical coordinate ok and
whether you put it if you use the
spherical coordinate which direction
you'd see this is your polar angle which
others as a musical it's all your
freedom and for this problem I'm going
to do this one as my theta
okay and then say XD plan is asthma as a
mule plan so with that I have a if again
I suit so in this case I assume V is
isotropic okay and real crystal they are
not isotropic so soon V is isotropic so
I have a cosine theta that's way wide
and DF DG dy plus g e-- course the
right-hand side is a term that depends
only on X right we access see if we
actually have to be careful it's to
depend on theta phi but doesn't depend
on Y ok so I solve this equation and the
way I solve it in fact because this is a
function of X so you will say gee months
s 0 x equals it's a homogeneous equation
you you to a new variable G minus s 0
and there is a way cosine theta so I
have a say exponential minus y way
cosine theta right that's my solution
and you plug in this back into here you
don't believe it that you can check I
should be 0 okay so this is my ass
solution and I say that we need a
boundary condition right either y equals
0 the Y 40 the boundary if it's the
boundary is diffuse so it goes out
isotropically that corresponding to f0
this go f going out is equal f 0 so g
equals 0 at the y equals 0 because f
equal f 0
so G equals 0 y equals zero so i have c
equals s 0 so what I have it's g equals
4 4 theta at the y equals 0 then this
means that theta is a larger than 60
light less than 90 degree I have G
equals s 0 and exponential mass of why
the cosine theta nice one and cosine
theta is also called the rational cosine
mule equals the directional cosine theta
so that's just a symbol so i can write
in terms of meal rather than take the
whole cosine theta okay so this is a 4y
equals 0 and similarly you look at the
upper plan you will say g equals again
s0 and the exponential if i look at this
will be d minus y gamma oh do i miss it
how i should have a towel somewhere i
have towel I should let me do this I put
it all on both sides so rather
extrication tau Y tau D G dy plus G
equals minus tau YX the f0 dt dt DX ok
experts say I put a G so this is a towel
I have tau so that should be tau tau x
rays mean free path ok so tall x away is
mean free path and divide that mule I'm
nice one and this is a 4 theta is less
than 180 degree
larger than 90 degree and this is a the
flowing from the leaving the first
surface the upper surface into the media
so what I have here you can say this is
the exponential decay because the course
I'm you in 90 to 180 is negative so this
is always say it's a from surface it
decays surface the decays that's how I
decide my son physically physically you
can think about the feet in physical
term okay so I have the solution for G
that means I now my F because the f is f
0 plus G so once I know if I can go to
find out what's the heat transfer right
so I can find other words the heat
transfer my heat transfers rule the any
plan of X is I have to say this gives me
any point along the Y direction right so
I sum up with a flux integral over Y
direction and integrate over Y so it's 0
to y 0 to D over D Y and then my every
flux I still have what I have way x
times the H bar Omega and times the f
that's my sake KX KY kz this is the
weather where i started when i write the
flux for the transport now because this
quantity is the function y i integrate
the Y to get photo right and now you
should be comfortable converting the
summation into integration and so what I
have 0 to D and D Y and the summation to
integration what i have is i'm using
spherical coordinates theta phi and the
way way is a constant it is my frequency
see i am usually going to the frequency
domain so i have 0 2 omega max D Omega
and 0 to PI D Phi and 0 to PI D theta
and I have the rest is a way X H bar
Omega F right this is f now
is say f 0 plus G right so g four
different direction i have different
solution there the depend i have to
split this 0 to pi integration into two
terms there were two lining degree so i
can use this g 90 to 180 degree i use
the bottom g right ok and the VX so
what's my way x my VX so now you see
because i took the easy X Y Direction
see how I by the ratchet so I have to
project that way into X direction and
that way if I project that remember it's
a spherical coordinate right we actually
the V times sine theta that goes to as a
mutual plan X Z direction and the fight
that as a muser angle if I aligned to
the X direction that well I have a
cosine Phi so this one is a way sine
theta cosine Phi so this is VX and now
when I do slowly angle is a seat hard d
theta D Phi sine see that easy that if i
right why do from cadichon to spherical
coordinate i have a sine theta d theta D
Phi and then I have density of states
divided by four PI because that ends up
States was for the integrator the whole
solid angle right so this is they are
the conversion have to do and at the end
that you see I have to do all those
integrations and this integration you
cannot do if we ever sent depends on
frequency relaxation time because the
here s0
I have tau i have another VX okay so
actually i will get a VX square right so
here i will have waste squared sine
theta squared cosine Phi square okay
otherwise you'll get a 0 0 if it's just
a question i see that 0 to 2pi you guys
zero that but i have a square okay and
if you do your integration i will skip
the detail what you have is
here is I want you to really sit down
and make up the missing derivations but
to say I'm going to give you the result
you will see and if say the cow and the
way our constant or you can say the tau
x way equals me free pass a constant ok
so here my condition is the mean free
path is a constant you go to frisk
problem right when people do rarefied
gas dynamics they typically take
constant tau you do heat transfer people
typically to cancel mean free path I
don't say very good justification for
those choices but because of those
different choices the final result looks
like different okay and so if I do this
and of course the UN surely you can
write this as your minus okay but
because you integrate so it's d DT DX
and this is the effective thermal
conductivity and the end result of all
the integration is the K effective / k
which is the bulk because in the
solution we have the here DF 0dt this
essentially also give you the bulk
thermal conductivity so then I'm going
to Lorelei's it
I have a factory with a bulk equals a1
a3 plus a 1 minus the e3 because a mass
e 52 c and this essay is the long
dimension or sickness thickness / mean
free path and AE is an exponential
function equals defined as 0 to 1 mil
and must to exponential mass could say
over milk d mu so this is a function
that in the past that people actually
turbulent it's a integral function of
order n so this is a where I say if you
take a constant relaxation time you're
not gather this year and you actually
get a different exponential that's where
the difference okay so if you plot this
effective thermal conductivity of
materials this is York assay which is d
over mean free path right and this is
normalized effective over K bulk let's
say bulk and it goes so this happens
when this transition goes to this is of
the order one you approach the Box
American activity when the material is
very sick compared to mean free path but
it is more you have the deviation from
this moon river so this are they another
nanostructure your say those property
you enjoy your show that go back to bulk
when you make it a thick enough and then
you if you have a theory your sanity
check right when you go back to the bulk
modess a sickness do you get the bulk
properties
and so this is this solution is also
called focus on the hammer solution
sounder hammer a sounder hammer okay now
I'm putting a solution and it was
developed for electrical transport so
the original study was not on thermal
conductivity was measuring the electric
conductivity of films that turns out to
be smaller and the solution is identical
for electrical and thermal transport so
you can also say this could be the
electric conductivity / the bulk
electric conductivity and the thickness
/ bulk electron mean free path you all
have the same behavior and this is
because the surface scatter but okay ah
here we assuming just a common we
assuming that they feel deposited the
same as amateur bulk material and very
often this is actually not the case
because when you deposit the film for
example you put a silver on silicon what
happens is it's not a single crystal
it's a grins so in fact I see the
nucleation when you deposit the material
on top of a substrate first you have a
location so the atoms nuclear there are
small dots and then so there are a lot
of a single small crystals and when you
further deposit it some of the smaller
christer disappear the larger crystal
win so your crystal grow larger and
larger so the grinch actually criticize
another constant and in this case what
do you measure is not just the surface
effects but the interface also be
the green interface are scattering
centers so you just can't always say and
so this in fact that happens at the
surface the interface is awesome okay
and the other commander is if you have a
specular surface you can again solve the
equation but the boundary condition
change the accounting condition and in
this case what you say is that the
specular surface do not degree that your
textbook you get what the ratio
approaching one and the reason is if you
think about this specular even though
there's the ration change but they still
the same model so this is the original
gold here but here so in terms of
transporting the X Direction the same
there's no effect in scatter the
scattering so it's sort of like a wave
guide you bounce your light in an
optical fiber as analyzing your fiber
surfaces specular for light they go
forward right and they're also solution
for partially specular partially diffuse
so all those are existing solutions okay
ah so the in fact that the original
observation those are the classical side
effect and the first experiment was done
by Casimir not cannot not first the
theory was done back hassinger so Kazmir
turns out to be a say he did there are
many customary effects and one of those
is on heat conduction where he explained
this Casimir effect the bass down
because there are some experiment on
diamond right I showed before I come out
before thermal conductivity of Vulcan
Materials always looking like this right
at the very low temperature it's
proportional to specific heat and that's
because there is no internal scattering
the mean free path is limited by the
boundaries so those early experiment
besides the fact was in ninety 20s and
Kazmir had the theory i think it was in
1920s and I sure I forget it's 1921 1910
and lining Henry near the range but say
he was explaining those effects using
the boundaries scanner so it's also
Casimir effect one further comment and
in fact those are the things we're
writing a paper on coherence and I was
thinking this weekend where is this d co
harsh coming from right so if I have a
film when looking at the implant the
Russian but the next one I'll talk about
this direction right so if there is no
scattering inside the photon will
propagate the eyes of a packet right but
they don't get it if there's no
scattering that we packet and propagate
at the way so the face is actually
maintained right so it's a coherent
transport interior heated surface when
he's the surface the Casimir treatment
here is the company that diffuse out
right so they're your face is randomized
and when you're randomized that when you
come back again any of this fall on that
launched it from the any direction that
part is still coherent but it's not a
lot of interfering with this one that
going up that the Russian because the
FISA randomized so this are they see
these are the classical regime classical
size is a region doesn't mean there is
no phase coherence idol so I think what
I'll do next you have heard a lot now
and really it's time to let's take a
look at other the recent literature now
you look at it
oh no not this one
I would say that you probably if you
look carefully on those papers you
should be able to enlist attach
something that we talked in this class
in many many journals
I think it's a good to look at that
let's take a look at the nano letters
again oops
okay so i would I there to see that now
you should say look at the over fifty
percent some of this juror you should
you should have heard something and then
you should not be afraid of looking at
it graphene ok so maybe how quantum
transport you have ballistic transport
and solar cell ok we are going to talk
about the solar sail soon as i mentioned
that say like some of those protein
let's skip that what do you think about
this one single molecule to detect
directed tivity enhance the raman
scattering using nano attendant so i
would think about it see ramen this
probably related might be related to
surface plasmon where you got it there's
an antenna either there you have higher
energy density no coral eyes the density
of states is a high so you will not be
surprised if you read the tents up
states or those terminology when you
look at the paper and when you have a
high local density of state for
electromagnetic wave you can have a
higher Rama in effect right and look
more I met my comment may not be right
you can open the paper and see what it's
talking about and that's when I do I say
okay anything interesting maybe that's
not icic enough of a lot of this stuff
so Van Dyke transporting strongly
coupled and dope the quantum dot what
doesn't mean so quantum dot has a
discrete energy levels
when you put them together and the
energy levels start the overlap and form
a new band that's my interpretation this
paper is going to be talking about all
right I didn't look at my my gas
you should go back to check and see how
correct up what I said is correct or not
are selective gassings and with a single
pristine graphene transistor what's this
about anybody can guess
what happens is when gas attached to a
surface you will change the charge
inside and you measure your lectric
conductivities your change and then when
I look at title okay the question is the
weather you can tell which guess you're
measuring right you will you put any
dirt on top they conduct it with your
change so the question is looking to
tell which door it is right these people
do sensors or what is you have to be
specific I don't know what this one is
doing but I would assume it must be
doing some commenting or related the
right image on single go down with the
Nano where maybe Nana where is the proof
of the tunneling gear again I'm just
guessing okay i want the challenge you
go back and to develop the habit and
they say whether there since that you
should be paying more attention to this
one they send me a CD this is a work
that the aroma jinda and pinion together
they've been working on this many years
and what they observe is that the
thermal conductivity some rough and
desert wires has a low thermal
conductivity that cannot be explained
the Fuchs under from a theory with there
are many papers reading on this and some
people say because they use this they
claim they have high ZT silicon
nanowires and many people say that's not
the probably correct so there's been a
lot of time and recently found that the
thermal conductivity actually correlated
with a pure the the roughness different
mo different viewers here is this sort
of i forgot that what is this but but
they did at a frequency analysis and now
you fractal dimension whether that's
correct whether it's a wavy fact so
people are still a dis are very positive
this is a parliament result you can say
so that's directly related to the
failure of this one what I just said
okay surface plasma modification
spontaneous remission right so surface
plasma again you heard it a poster
effect a positive factor is relatable
cavity see it Li mix photonic band right
only every paper you can make some
comments no it's my point okay we're
chapter 7 we have three more chapter to
go and after that it should be able to
comment online in five percent of the
paper ok go back spend some time on and
see what I my guess ok it's correct and
you can make your own guess